who is Interpol and why are they so
upset at these security lapses it's a
cone in ternational organization of a
police cooperation and they share their
venue for sharing data about police
investigations the reason they're upset
is that they maintain a database of lost
and stolen passports among other things
and the Malaysian authorities or the
airline authorities evidently did not
check the manifest of this flight
against that database do we do that at
JFK we do why don't they do that around
the world I have been through I don't
want to disparage any airports but I've
been through major international
airports where you go you're kidding me
yeah there's a gap here is it in
retrospect there's no explanation for it
that will satisfy anyone I mean it's
just a failure on the part of them if
that's what happened if it wasn't some
sort of computer glitch with a failure
you're part of the carrier and the
airport authority at KL we keep coming
back to this idea that foul play can't
be ruled out tell us a little bit about
Malaysia because the majority of
Malaysia is Muslim and we know the
country hasn't seen any recent major
terrorist attacks on its soil but it has
been used as a transit hub and a
planning hub right yes I'll true i mean
in fact it featured in the 911 plot now
quite some time ago but it was one of
the places where the plotters got
together before coming to attack of the
United States it has some domestic
internal problems but mainly it's a
trance state it's a facilitation hub
it's in a very strategic location
Richard oz a question please for dr.
Falcon res is your sense that oat since
nine eleven that the four terrorists
airplanes and Airlines by and large are
not the volta most vulnerable air does
this surprise you so there's certainly
not as vulnerable as there were pre 911
what is interesting and what surprised
me is they continue to go after them so
despite an extraordinary global effort
and US effort to protect international
air travel systems these continue to be
targeted we also see innovation in bomb
making techniques particularly out of
the Arabian Peninsula so our bomb
detection technology had really focused
on finding metal on a person or in in a
checked bag now it shifted to liquids
which are not detectable but metal it is
for instance the reason why you no
longer can bring a soda or a liquid onto
an aircraft it's because we know of a
bomb-making recipe that only involves
liquids no metallic parts Richard
connected
for us with China because it suffered a
terrorist attack so it says last week by
a Muslim ethnic group the wiegers is
there a link here between what we've
seen in Malaysia what we could see in
China and this idea that terrorism place
if you see that written anywhere wait
that link well there well they're worth
well there's been suggested a three
people killed by machete-wielding people
and all Don in a remote I think safety
at the moment there's no evidence of
that whatsoever that this is all
connected so eager separatists in China
there have been wieger attacks in
mainland China this is not their mo and
so you what you've got here is it's not
uncommon with cases like this in the
early stages is thousands of dots and
what connects them is that is the stuff
of the investigation and that will
emerge over the coming days I've no
doubt and while our conversation is
certainly leading towards some sort of
foul play we still don't know exactly
what happened it could have been a
mechanical issue Richard in again you
were the deputy in charge of security
here for the police department advise
the White House you're not an FAA
inspector but when an ocean or when an
airliner goes down over the ocean you're
trying to get a black box I mean can you
really get data out of there that it is
going to be able to help solve what
happened yeah once you get the black box
you'll be able to tell pretty careful
pretty precisely what it is because of
the telemetry that it records about all
the different systems they'll be able to
reconstruct work backwards to the type
of failure the air france play like the
air france flight it took two years to
get that black box the hard part here
there's about the investigation on the
ground in KL and it's not just the
passenger manifests that's going to be
looked at it's also the crew behind the
wall so one possibility is the passenger
brought a bomb aboard another is that it
was checked in and there was no human
being associated the third is that the
ground crew placed it on the vessel if
it's a bomb and all those possibilities
need to be resolved ambassador house
your council on foreign relations has
been looking at international relations
i'm gonna say back to world war two if
not earlier and there's this whole
backdrop of terrorism how you treated it
within your research i would say it's
part of the superstructure now of
international relations but as rich
falken wrath was pointing out
it has qualitatively changed over the
last 10 or 20 years in terms of its
capabilities it's globalization if you
will on the dark side and you now you
have forms of training recruiting monies
moving people are moving so it's become
much more of an international phenomenon
and in some ways I think much more
dangerous than one other thing time it's
also the court what motivates terrorists
have changed in the old days we used to
have like pasta terrorists or IRA Paris
much more narrow now you've got much
bigger terrorism global goal mechanisms
with much bigger ambitions I was going
to compare their to the killing of Anwar
Sadat in egypt which was a whole
different extra curse and when there's
no report yet linking this crash to
Terrell